let's talk about the uh the latest uh uh
social justice outrage though oh my gosh
my friends i give you the wmixon
controversy one of the greatest scandals
of this or any generation
and i imagine many of where he's gonna
turn this the podcast off you're like
this is stupid i don't care no hold on
hold on don't leave just yet
twitch which is a streaming service many
of you are probably familiar with it's
owned by amazon
it is ultra woke right so we had uh do
you know who destiny is cassandra
vaguely he's like a leftist streamer he
did
he was streamed on twitch he was a
partner and he said kyle rittenhouse was
clearly self-defense
and he's and he's a leftist right and he
and we had him on the show and he was
like it is the clearest case of
self-defense he's being chased
you know and then someone shoots they
kicked him off the partner program for
saying it wow that's how lefty twitches
yeah so twitch puts out this tweet
march is wimmickson's history month i'm
not kidding
w-o-m-x-n wimxin
join us in celebrating and supporting
all the wimmicks and creating their own
worlds building their communities and
leading the way on twitch
and then the word wim xin started
trending and
i was actually surprised to find it was
actually the woke left that was upset
over this
and there's a weird unity forming
between like the anti-woke and the woke
on this issue i gotta show you this
tweet from
count dankula he says imagine being
trans
and fighting your whole life to be
considered a full woman
and they instead change it to whimxion
to point out that you are still trans
lmao that's a good point he then said
leftists
stop retweeting this calling me based or
calling it a redemption arc when it's an
opinion i've held for years
dankela then says stop acting like i
like trans people i only like trans
people when i'm horny
dankela is clearly joking i want to
stress
the point is people are acting like
dankela is saying
something new like defending trans
people but he's actually
defended them quite a bit in the past
and he's pointing out
this new word whimxen which is like
going viral
twitter daily caller is an article okay
we'll read the daily caller
twitch gets dragged for declaring march
whimxion's history month oh they're not
gonna let me read it oh they will yeah
oh okay wymixon so this this is a funny
thing that happened
a while ago where some like british
organization
said you know wimmickson's rights or
something and then it created this huge
fight between the left and the left
because the left hates the left i guess
where they were like the word wimixon is
exclusive it removes trans women because
if trans women are women you only need
to say women right
that was my first reaction when i saw
the video i was like how is the left
doing this isn't the whole point to not
other these people
like now they're completely othering
them i saw it and i was just like if i
was a
trans person i feel like i'd be offended
yes and then they actually were so at
least good on them for
someone someone someone emailed me they
said that the x
means trans and so that's why they do
falx with an x
and they do whimx in oh really because
they're adding an x to everything
yeah i think i've not heard that that's
what someone said i guess it kind of
makes sense
and that's oh yeah like cross crossing
over interesting i guess what about
trans men are they mixing mxn
has that been a thing yet i don't it's
coming yeah i'm sure it is you just did
it there you go congratulations
i have mixed feelings about trans the
whole thing because i support people i
love people i want people to be happy
but when especially in sports like when
you see a trans
woman who was a man that transitioned
into a woman that is a male who
transitions
yeah just dominate other women in a
sport that it's
it's it's disturbing to me personally i
get disturbed because they're much
taller a lot of times their bone mass is
larger
um you'll see like these pictures of
like this large trans woman
just like muscling out these young these
smaller
you know women and um so people have
said maybe we should have a transports
and non-transport i think that's smart
well then that's the problem the same
problem of whmixon is you're creating a
new category
to separate people out this is an
impossible conversation
you know it's like no matter what side
you take the life gets mad at you
no matter what like there was one
prominent uh
trans woman creator who got cancelled
for claiming there were only two genders
and then it resulted it resulted in this
huge gen z versus millennial fight over
what it means to be trans because
i think as you can clearly see with like
twitches wimixon it's not the first time
they use this word like some
corporations use this word
everybody gets mad there was a really
funny uh venn diagram i saw earlier it's
a meme
and it's got like conservatives liberals
and leftists
and then it says like it says like
conservatives and leftists like guns
but you know liberals and conservatives
like capitalism
and then liberals and leftists hate
trump and then
for leftist and uh the one thing that
all of them were united by
was when they all overlapped it said
hates leftists
so like even even the leftists hate
leftists they do
they absolutely do so i i it's a
why would you want to be in that space i
have no idea that's a rough one
that it's almost like a self-hatred i
don't know where it comes from exactly
well because i think there's
conservative conservatives and liberals
who are tribal and don't like each other
but i think leftists
tend to be not always there are some
i'll i'll differentiate the progressives
from
the tribal leftists there are a lot of
progressives who are
great you know people like kalkalinsky
and crystal ball are good people
and then you have these weird leftists
who will just say whatever it is to
oppose anyone who's not a leftist
so they end up supporting really weird
nonsensical things like
25 000 armed national guard in dc with
razor wire fences
like why would it why would an
anti-fascist support this
because they're not really but they do
hate themselves that's why obama called
it a circular firing squad
the the the transports thing is uh uh
difficult conversation i suppose
mostly because i'll tell you this i just
recently had a conversation with someone
and like i'm i'm i'm actually not in an
agreement with most of the conservatives
on this stuff
like when it comes to uh pronouns and
things like that i tend to lean left a
lot of this stuff
but i was talking to someone and i said
with the equality act
which you guys know the quality act
passed in the house
it's where they're going to add gender
identity to the 1964 civil rights act
so my question was how do you protect
biological sex as a protected class
and gender identity at the same time you
can't
so but why do you think so because
you're taking away
women's spaces and female spaces
yeah and it's just i
personally don't see how it can co-exist
at all especially with sports
sports is like the big the big thing
where it's
really noticeable that this these things
collide
how are you going to protect little
girls who want to get scholarships and
these things that they've worked on
their whole life
when you know they're never going to win
against people who are bigger than them
have more testosterone than them
um i just so there there was
there is an interesting point someone
brought up when i was when i was arguing
with someone about this i was just
saying arguing having a conversation
because i wasn't really arguing with
anybody they said what about somebody
who's never gone through male puberty
and they're they've always been
either on puberty blockers or on
estrogen so they're
i mean i fully oppose putting on
children on puberty blockers
i mean like hardcore fully oppose this
but
i guess in that case it might be a
little bit different i know they're
doing testosterone tests
for uh at least professional sports so
stuff like that helps but you see like
i think it was this like mediocre male
runner beat the fastest woman in the
world
yeah and it's just like how are your
high school girls
i compete now i had a real interesting
conversation when i posted on
i was i have a bunch of lefty friends
and i posted on their facebook how do
you protect
biological sex and gender identity at
the same time and
what i said was imagine this and i use
the the showers example
as it's it's it's the easiest example to
become honest it is an easy argument
because showers are fairly visceral like
we
want privacy in our showers so there's
there's basically a court precedent that
says
you are allowed to discriminate so long
as an equal space is provided for
the other sects so when there was there
was a lawsuit in california at some
university over women's programs
the judge ruled no they're allowed
women's programs women's scholarships
because they have identical men's
scholarships
that's a really interesting court
precedent because that would you'd be
able to be like okay what about
segregation
well this week there was another court
case miss usa just won
they were sued by a trans woman who does
beauty pageants
and they because they refused to accept
anyone who wasn't a biological woman
and they just won and the court said
that it was because of freedom of
association
and then the lawyers for miss usa came
out and they were like you can have a
trans beauty pageant or you know
whatever you want to do
but this is for biological women and we
created a space
to showcase biological women yeah and so
you know there is another court case now
that's also setting a precedent i guess
that one yeah well so here's the point i
was making if
if you say that it is unfair for
biological
women to be in the men's space
because men are biologically different
the army just did a new training program
because men and women are different
if you say that you know that then
you've got title ix violation i guess
what originally happened was there was
no women's sports
and then a bunch of women sued saying
there should be a women's only division
because it's not fair so
we got women's sports so now they're
saying okay it's not discriminatory
because
there's a men's division in women's
division there are a bunch of sports
back in the 50s where they would not let
women run there's like a marathon and
women weren't allowed to be in it
today there is no rule in major league
sports barring women from competing and
so i'm talking it's really interesting
so
let me wrap up the first point and we'll
get into this one i was saying
if you have two a female in a male
locker room
showers and then you decide that
somebody who's biologically male can now
use the female
side because of an identity you've
essentially taken away
a safe space for one marginalized
community for another marginalized
community because you believe
one community is more marginalized than
the other but you can't quantify that
there's no
there's no number where you can be like
it's a seven on the impression scale and
a six on the oppression scale
so you're basically just saying the law
says based on sex
and identity but then you quite
literally have people arguing about
which one is more oppressed
and more deserving of that space or not
deserving of that space
so in the end what ends up happening is
i talked about this a long time ago i
got a lot of heat for it
you don't end up with a male men's
locker room in owen's locker room
and you know trans people using
whichever one they want in the uk what
ended up happening was they just started
building unisex showers
and then due to general proximity having
nothing to do with trans people mind you
biological males started assaulting
biological females it wasn't like they
just started doing it it was because
proximity breeds opportunity i suppose
and there was a study that came out it
was in the fine i think it was in the
telegraph or the
i think it was a sunday times i'm not
sure british paper saying they saw a
huge spike in
men males assaulting females because now
these showers and changing rooms
were in the same place and skeezy awful
dudes
had an opportunity now to do it so they
did so the question then
is how do you protect both the same time
if they're both in it
in the in the civil rights act i don't
know some people have pointed out that
we'll just have a functioning society
where people know what the social rules
are you know like we don't violate
social norms so people will just get
along
but a really funny thing happened i
pointed out
that showers are an easy example but
what about the wnba
right if if if you can't discriminate on
the basis of sex or identity
couldn't someone go to the wnba and say
i should be allowed as a biological male
to compete in this
and then the response was how come you
you already can't discriminate in the
basis of sex so how come no one has done
that
that's a good point no guy is actually
apparently i mean maybe i'm not maybe
this is wrong
tried to get in there was a guy who sued
hooters
because they wouldn't hire him and then
a court ruled give him the job and then
he was like no i don't know
i don't want the job something
interesting happened
i pointed out that major league sports
don't
actually discriminate on the basis of
sex nba nfl mlb
women are allowed to play you never have
there's no rule there's no rule
and so i was told repeatedly by these
lefties that's not true they won't allow
women to play and i said
that that's incorrect and i sent him an
article from espn
about women trying out for the nfl to be
kickers
and they had numerous quotes from high
rank high profile
uh coaches and and scouts saying
women just don't make the cut and so the
response i got from the leftist was
i don't understand how is that possible
maybe maybe a social stigma is making
the women not play as well
well has a woman ever won something like
the boston marathon
because that's not maybe for gender
segregated
i probably for women's yeah i don't
think that anyone
i can't think of a woman though who's
won the entire like who's actually been
first through the finish
i don't think so matter like four
minutes and 30 seconds i think
just blow women out of the water
relatives no it's like a time where 45
minutes or something well
so no i'm talking about i wanna i wanna
i wanna stress this point the person
arguing with me said when i told them
women
are not barred from major league sports
he's like then why aren't they in
on the teams and then i very simply said
well uh
exposure to prenatal testosterone
results in more fast twitch muscles
which mean men have the ability to use
burst energy like jump higher
sprint faster and burn off energy much
more quickly they tend to have denser
bones double the collagen they tend to
be taller these are all tendencies not
absolutes
and then he said the response was could
there be a social stigma preventing the
women from actually scoring better
and i was like is that that's what they
think there could be
that they've maybe if a woman goes in
the locker room and gets raped like that
could be a disturbing thing because they
only have one locker room
but so i could see that women maybe
wouldn't want to put themselves in that
position
but they're also taking the most extreme
freaks of nature to play in the sport
and those tend to be men if not
always you know the strongest of the
strong of the humans
are male i don't know if that's always
true it's the highest top
1.01 percent of people who are playing
in any of these sports and they're like
always
male i mean for the most part aren't
they so the point i'm bringing up is
this leftist
genuinely believes that if you took the
average biological female and biological
male there is nothing stopping them from
competing equally
and that's to me it shows how culty it's
become
like absolutely we should have laws
protecting marginalized groups and all
that stuff
we should have equal access to civil
rights people should be respected and
allowed to live freely
but come on if you're talking about
averages yeah i could see that but
we're talking about extremes for
professional sports you want the
extremes of human nature
right the point is this person genuinely
believed the average male and female
would compete on equal footing and
physical activities
do you know why that is i think i know
why it is
yes exactly it is the blank slate theory
um it's something that john jack
rousseau talked about
and he talked about how humans start out
being basically completely equal and
are completely shaped by the culture
they grow up in we know this is not true
like we can literally look at the
physical differences between males and
females you can look at the pelvis size
and shape
and you know the angle of the female
pelvis is completely different like
there's no i don't know person
i don't know i i we we have a we have
two women and two men in here oh yeah
and there's just
they're completely identical in every
way you got to play some bad guys
completely yeah we are completely
different
i mean you both have long hair i think
cassandra
doesn't kick further than me i'm sure
you can both feed me at arm wrestling
yeah for sure i'd be toast who's taller
he's taller yeah i think we're all about
the same size he's faster i don't tim
i don't know maybe thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you